[Music]
thank you
the what podcast which bands this year
that matter we are just days away from
learning uh the lineup for 2023 Berry
Taco very excited to see you guys uh the
anticipation mounting are you starting
to shiver with anticipation are you
quivering
yeah happy New Year happy New Year oh
yeah how's the holiday what'd you guys
doing it was good yeah we're had a bunch
of family events and uh had a had a
toddler stay with us for a week Taco you
went to Barry's house yeah yeah he
destroyed everything yeah
dranko is PBR yeah
we eat everywhere yeah everywhere that's
right yeah we're we're finding things in
places we didn't know they could be put
including your butt hey
[Laughter]
fair enough fair enough
um so so what did you do Taco it was the
holiday Lake
uh took the nephew down to the lake
where my aunt lives and got on the boat
got to ride the boat around
boats and buses this man has a uh
he's he's right in right in the pocket
isn't he he never really changes never
really wavers
boats and hoes
when I think of you that's the first few
words that come to mind absolutely
that's right how was everything how was
everything up there you know it's weird
I was uh just talking about this I made
a list I just scribbled this morning
when I woke up all the shows that I've
seen since moving to New York and I'm
sure I'm gonna miss some of them but I'm
it's somewhere like 48 and you know I'm
not trying to say that oh look at me but
but there is this thing of
I know that it's difficult for some
people and that's why you know they love
Bonnaroo and go to Bonnaroo every year
or Coachella Etc but man it's when you
have access to all of these shows up
here it really does you know change your
perspective on you know going to these
festivals I can't imagine if I went to
all of these shows how much this would
cost me I have no idea how much this
would cost me but it's a it's a
it's a lineup right it is a festival
lineup that you know you look around and
if you ask me to spend 300 on this
that's a steal it's an absolute steal I
know I know it's nuts I've thought about
that you know when it sounds like you
said it sounds like you're bragging or
whatever but it's like oh I've seen them
I've seen them you know it's all that
show saw that show it's incredible you
the number of bands and acts that you
get to see at a festival
speaking of you know he's brought
Coachella did did I did you say that
there was a Coachella rumor I feel like
we should have had the Coachella lineup
by now
I thought they're I'm I mean I'm looking
at a story that uh
uh oh this was this was the thing that
came out this morning about Drake
um yeah and the yeah okay I remember Bad
Bunny yeah
yeah so um I I feel like Coachella
lineup is quite late I always feel like
we get it sometime around
you know the first of December am I
wrong about that
uh that I don't remember
seems like you know
around this time we get they start
coming as we know is we're going to
probably it's always before Bonnaroo
it's always before Bonnaroo and based on
our chat with Corey and Brad they
basically told us when the lineup's
coming out and we've got what 10 12 days
we're looking at it with probably
January 12th
um
so yeah I I I'm kind of surprised if if
Bonnaroo gets a lineup out before
Coachella that's I don't know when's the
last time that has happened has that
happened before maybe I'm crazy here
that I remember
let's see is it gonna be the 12th yeah I
think it's I think that's what they told
us oh yeah
Thursday
it's always me the two two Tuesday the
10th it's gonna be a Tuesday yeah it's
Tuesday the 10th yeah so
um best ideas just go back and listen to
the episode with Brad and Corey they
tell us when it's coming out
so yeah we could just do that it'd be a
lot easier
uh actually if I remember right you told
us and they didn't deny okay okay
so we can take that however you want I
also asked them about Taylor Swift and
they did deny
[Music]
[Laughter]
a little bit about uh Bonnaroo and some
some rumors and and uh ideas and
speculations uh here in a little bit but
we have a special guest today that if
you went through the lineup of guests
that we've had on the show they would be
probably our three-night headliner you
know they'd play three shows because
they not only are our house band but
also very good friends and I think still
hold the record and
it's just going to add it to the the
overall count today the overall record
of most podcast appearances
aren't they a top of our list
they're up there um yeah I think that's
why their their band name is repeat
repeat because they repeat yes
rinse rinse yeah repeat repeat repeat
repeat repeat yeah uh yeah the kids have
uh repeat repeat Jared and Kristen
repeat are our guest today uh for a lot
of reasons mostly because
yeah they have a new album out but
we haven't talked to him all season all
last year we didn't have him on the show
Once
I was going to say mostly because we
like them yeah that's why and they're
fun yeah they're a lot of fun and uh and
well we'll talk about it when when they
come on but uh
yeah they've they are as much a part of
our show as anybody really yeah in their
own way they're the fourth you hear
they're the fourth and fifth hosts
yeah yeah and they did our theme song
I love these oh yeah I'll talk about the
theme song here in a second Let's uh
step away for a second when we come back
repeat repeat our guests on the web
podcast
[Music]
and there's Jared's crotch
how exciting
look at these look at these beautiful
faces can you hear us coming in hot here
you are coming in really hot how are you
guys oh we are good just dialing in
everything wait a second is are you in
the studio is this the the fame Studio
on the hill yeah oh wow wow look at that
look at that first off take us around
the studio explain the new space because
it's fully outfitted now right it's
fully outfitted yes uh I'm worried that
if I unplug my laptop that um no you
don't have to do that it's okay you
don't do that you know just tell me
about it tell me about the room
um it's so pretty it's so well done it's
like a 600 square foot Cabin in the
Woods uh that also sleeps like eight so
you can come from out of town and make a
record and stay for a week or more and
uh it's awesome it's like our little
getaway for us to make music and for
other artists to come and make music and
we have this amazing view that's like
hundreds and hundreds of Acres faces
Sunset and it's up here in the Tennessee
Foothills it's great we saw it I saw the
the Drone thing that you put out oh my
God
how dreamy is that space how dream is
have you yeah we lived here for two
to do something with it and then the
pandemic sort of helped guide us into
what we would be doing with it and that
is making music from home yeah so yeah
now we just come up here every day and
see what we can all right so the walk
from the house to the hill you know how
many like Barnyard animals do you have
to dodge
well on our property and then we have
neighbors that have a rooster and
chickens and yeah and cows and
everything like that there's crows up
here and deer why you know we have a
family of deer that live up here so
at any given moment it's like a Disney
movie it's like Bambi walking by or
something yeah that's really good
seriously there was like a baby deer
that grew up here and so I'd have
artists up here and like at any given
I'd be like oh my God there's like a
baby yeah
it's it's wild I've had artists that
have made records over the last like six
months that have watched this baby deer
grow up because every time they come out
and he's like a little bit bigger do you
feel like you're constantly entertaining
though when you have people on the
property at all times it feels like you
gotta constantly just it's like you're
running an Airbnb it's less like
entertaining because we built the
studios it used to feel a little bit
more like that when we were when my
studio was out of our house but uh okay
now it's nice because there's like
separation so at any point I can be like
I'm gonna go make lunch and I can just
leave and go do my own thing for a
minute so it's nice and then when
artists come from out of town and stay
for a while like they get to have their
own little you know place to stay so
it's uh it feels a lot less less like
entertaining and more like I'm coming in
on there
ah okay it's good how much are you how
much is it used by you versus other
artists well I mean I'm up here every
day uh I spend about half the week
mixing and then the other half producing
uh and uh but I I mean this last year I
had artists here almost six days a week
if wow yeah and then just mixing in my
off time so are they mostly Nashville
artists are they coming from all over
it's about all over uh the first band
that stayed overnight was here from
Omaha so yeah and then West Virginia and
some people come and stay from Nashville
you know it's only an hour drive from
Nashville so there's artists that you
know you there's not a lot of Studios I
feel like where you get to come and
record but also kind of just like clear
your mind
and uh you know it's shorter Drive than
going to like Gatlinburg or something so
uh it's it's nice you feel far enough
away from the city but you're close
enough that you could you know get home
in time for well what is it and you
might be able to to say it as as
somebody who's recorded there but I
wonder how it changes somebody from out
of Town's writing perspective and how
they start hearing things a little bit
differently I you know Phoenix uh they
they wrote their last album in the at
the Louvre uh so and they recorded it
inside the and you know I can't imagine
that didn't change the way that they you
know wrote listen back you know produced
Etc
we've had a lot of people say that
coming out here has sort of reawakened
something creative in them I think just
because
there there aren't a lot of places
outside of Nashville that you can unless
your friend owns a place there's not
like really any other kind of built-in
like artist kind of retreat sort of
thing so we've had a lot of people come
out and just the fact that they can't
see Neighbors and there's no light
pollution and no noise you know they're
just sort of forced to I mean we do have
like a projector in Roku in here but
nobody really watches it because that's
not really what they're here to do so
people kind of like Zen out I feel like
yeah and it makes them feel more
creative at least like there have been a
few people that have been recurring
artists that have recorded out here
several times over the last year and
they've just sort of been like wow I
feel completely renewed I I tried to
base uh the studio and the work I do off
of all the experiences I've had in
studios since I was a teenager
um the good ones and the bad ones and I
tried to think about like what were the
things that I didn't like so much about
reporting in other Studios and while
there are plenty of studios in Nashville
that have really amazing gear I have
found that you know so much of it
doesn't really matter about the gear so
much of it matters about the vibe is the
most important right and all my favorite
producers are the same way uh you know
so I I think that uh a big element of it
is that you know I was trying to think
when we built it like what can we offer
that maybe other studios in Nashville
can't offer uh and you know so many
students I've recorded and have either
been in somebody's basement or have been
in like a strip mall you know and so it
doesn't really give you a lot to look at
and take in and so I think like that is
a huge thing that at least we can bring
yeah but you can get your nails done
exactly do a little shopping exactly and
one of the things things we do out here
since it is so isolated is we have a
stocked snack kitchen
that we've never had in other Studios
and we would find ourselves sitting you
know in other Studios for 12 and 14 hour
days wishing we had brought food so out
here we sort of eliminate that and have
a stacked yeah snack cabinet yeah okay
unless family let's Family Feud this
number one snack on the board is what oh
Vitas dark chocolate velveetas
that's the weirdest answer but yeah I
yeah if you gave me a thousand that is
not what it's gonna say worse yeah we're
like we're like uh we're like being on a
flight it's like the game goes out on
like airplanes tell me there's the
cookie that you're supposed to eat for
breakfast
nice nice it's so interesting this
because I've you know so many different
uh bands and interviews and artists it
changes it you know I think I can't
remember who I was talking to some
artist not that long ago and they said
we recorded it in a house because I
didn't want to be in a studio because I
didn't want it to feel like we were
going to work
every day and clocking in and then I've
had others who say I wanted to go into a
studio because I wanted that
professional
feeling and sound and all that so it
just it just changed all over the place
right I mean
yeah like it's I'm
because there's a time and place for all
of that you know yeah I mean also this
is now my work so I was telling Kristen
like the next our next record I I want
to kind of go into a different studio
and work with some other producers
because we just put out a 27 songs yeah
I'm just about to say your next record I
made a record that's good enough for
five years you're right well and I've I
made it all here and so it's like now
this is work so it's like after like
eight ten hours in the studio with
another artist the last thing I want to
do is come back up here and do it for
myself I'd rather go in another
environment or like with with some other
people so I think it's just time and
place you know there's there's times
where I feel most creative just in my
element here and there's times where I
feel most creative kind of getting out
of my comfort zone
yeah well let's talk about the album
here in a second but first uh how was
the holiday how have you guys been doing
I'm still very
very holiday mode I don't think we have
to remind ourselves
the week it was today my mom is here
from Texas yeah we were watching a movie
in bed until like 10 minutes ago so yeah
we're very much relaxing animals yeah
we're still holidaying nice uh what what
what movie was it oh God it's called
triangle of sadness and it is that's
lovely morning uh it's easy watch Brad
you would like it a lot it's kind of
like a twisted Wes Anderson movie yeah
oh it's really good that's that's you me
and Barry the triangle of sadness yeah
exactly
uh it's good it's got Woody Harrelson
it's so it's so weird because I'm
watching the triangle sadness in my
rectangle of sadness yeah it's
it's really um what's the word light
like quirky yeah well you know you guys
you guys made pandemic and quarantine
cool before like pandemic and quarantine
living out there uh in the woods with
the animals did you get into like the
Glass Onion stuff have you like how much
are you binging what are you are you
watching like every television show that
ever existed well no we were really late
to White Lotus but we did finally join
that party over this break yeah okay so
I feel a little bit mainstream now that
we've done that one yeah but like we've
never seen Game of Thrones and stuff
like that for example me neither not one
second what's the one that everybody
really likes um on with the guy from
Saturday Night Live that that uh that's
on he's a coach yeah where he's a coach
oh Ted lasso yeah so like I have to
remind myself because we uh sorry if you
all liked Ted lasso but we watched like
two episodes I was like and the other
Jared I know Jared so it's incredible so
yeah too sweet what is it too sweet for
you I'm too bitter I think he can't get
it that's why you would like to Triangle
sadness Brad because it's [ __ ]
need some angst shows yeah you don't
even do a shit's creek I know you're
only partial bingers oh my God yeah so
when so when Kristin was like we think
we should like watch this show
everybody's been talking about it and
I'm like everybody's been talking about
Ted lasso so you know that's not a basis
that I can go off of it's not for lack
of wanting we've tried to get into that
and Game of Thrones and all of it but I
don't know we just have a weird tape we
like really dystopian things really like
really super quirky things and we like
documentaries we're you know we're I'm
Not a Hipster well Brad mentioned it I
highly recommend the Glass Onion just if
for no other reason because of genetics
this movie is stupid okay so stupid it
is so dumb I don't disagree but she
really like terrific knives out but yeah
Knives Out was great I like okay I like
that a lot better but this this one is
just goofball [ __ ] okay it is so
dumb um but what I so I I had this hard
and fast rule that I don't suggest
things to people right I don't like
giving people the oh you've got to watch
because not only am I putting like at
risk your time but also if you don't
like it how does that reflect back on me
it all comes back to me uh but well I
will say I will say I have been out of
control and love with this show called
Fleischman is in trouble yeah I've heard
it's very good I am out of my mind about
this show I've never seen it's the best
show I've seen since breaking bad and it
like it doesn't there's nothing that has
perfectly described a midlife crisis or
written you know tragic divorce better
than better than the show
um it's out of control incredible we're
out of control we're really into
secession it's really we really like
that one and I don't know if I've ever
told you this but like TV is the only
medium where you can be like you got to
get into this series and it's like you
just have to give it a few episodes and
it's like each episode's like an hour
[ __ ] long and it's like no other
medium works like that it's not like oh
this Metallica album it's terrible no
you got to listen to it for like four
hours and then you'll love it yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's like it doesn't work in
any other art media
wait you're telling me I have to read uh
The Great Gatsby seven times before I
really get it okay I'll do it right yeah
yeah listen to it again that's a good
point uh so the holiday was good you
have family in town now uh we haven't
talked to you in a year so I guess this
whole year has been you know writing
250 songs and then putting them all out
at once huh yeah
yeah what'd you what did you leave out
yeah
not into them by the time it's time for
them to come out I like them when we
record them and then I'm not into them
by the time
by the time they come out
uh we really that's how I dated yeah
we realized pretty uh quickly at just
kind of wrapping up the year that
between our music and the music that
I've worked on in the studio we had a
song that either we recorded or that we
had a hand in producing come out at
least one if not two a week every week
for the whole year
so that was kind of a Jesus a crazy uh
you know
oh
yeah
literally today what
one of the artists I work with she was
like I'm surprising everybody with the
release today I had thought all the
songs had come out for the year I was
like cool I don't have to do any more
promotion for a few more days and then
I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm like I gotta make a
post about that like she just released a
song that I recorded and whatever came
out today so it's like yeah it's uh it's
it's fun are you gonna are you gonna
easy I sound this is are you gonna turn
this into like a Dan Arbok easy I sound
thing I mean and start pressing your own
vinyl on the farm that would be cool I
mean I sometimes people asked if I
wanted to like start a label but that's
the last thing I want to do but uh I
just want to help I I want to make
records and whatever that looks like so
it's funny when uh when this record came
out Brad sent us taco and I attacked and
said repeat repeats released in an album
today I said are they going to do it on
vinyl he said no it's like 27. yeah I
don't think this is going to be on vinyl
it's gonna be an eight record set
the pandemic years collectively like we
just needed kind of a place for all of
that stuff to funnel towards so that we
can shift creatively you know I mean
even just the aesthetic of like the
single artwork that I was doing that I
started doing in 2020 not having any
idea we would have so many by the end
you know I told Jared like I gotta do
something different all of this stuff I
didn't know we were gonna have you know
almost 30 songs in the same you know
style same palette yeah exactly so we we
both just kind of feel ready to like
shift
um This Record
had very specific like purposes for us
in that each song is sort of some
exercise and something we wanted to try
so it's either each song is either
inspired by you know one of our favorite
songs from other bands or it's something
we wanted to try production wise you
know or I I use the record as my
um
basically like my portfolio to learn how
to produce records so every song there's
like a technique that I wanted to try so
it's like there's a song on the record
that was like my I'm gonna try wall of
sound here and there's a technique yeah
it's like you know there's a song on the
record that's like I'm gonna try using
like analog Reverb or whatever so every
song was a way for me to experiment on
myself
so that I could learn how to do that for
other artists and so it was really fun
to get because there was a lot less
pressure I think because it was just
like oh if I [ __ ] this up it's just
our music you know I don't know it's
like it's fun to just like mess with
things and then that way now when bands
come in like I want to have the wall of
sound thing or whatever like I have a
little bit more knowledge on it I'm so
glad to hear you say that it's hard to
interrupt you Brad because when I was
listening to it um that's the phrase
that kept kind of coming through my own
head was y'all had some [ __ ] to work out
when whether it was musically or
lyrically or whatever it just feels like
you were working a lot of stuff out yeah
well in the beginning a lot of it was
Jared working out
light
a career change via lyrics you know I
mean your sort of life change between
touring all the time and making music
from home and just kind of that
transition as an artist I think a lot of
the songs were sort of well our last
tour before the pandemic was plain
a month of Arenas with the ma with
Modest Mouse and The Black Keys so we
played that and then the year ended and
then the pandemic hit
and everything shut down for two years
so rather quickly I had to realize you
know what do I want the next chapter of
my life to look like and uh you know I
felt like I could use this time to
really hone in some other skills and and
see what else I could bring to the table
well you know you just mentioned the The
Black Keys the Modest Mouse tour coming
off of that and then into kovid that
could breed a lot of insecurity and to
think that you were so confident to say
ah you know what let's just um do a
bunch of stuff that I don't know how to
do and see what happens and then on top
of it put it out into the world
not just once but twice yeah you know
you got two you got two versions of all
these things too so you know the the
lack of insecurity in a lot of this is
what I it's just an audacious project
and I give you a lot of credit for it
it's uh and plus
you know me and I've told you this since
the moment this is the best you guys
have sounded since
um since I've I mean since the beginning
I think this album is fantastic you you
know every song that you've ever sent me
every song that I've listened to it just
feels like it's getting better and
better and better and better uh thank
you uh I will say there was and still is
always a lot of insecurity uh but I
think what helped a lot for us was the
most terrifying moment I think for us
was putting out the first song uh posts
our last record glazed because our last
record we worked with uh you know the
Black Keys on and you know Michelle
Branch sang on it and it well we you
know it brought us a lot of accolades
and got debuted and billboard and
everything like that and so to have all
of these things and then over the
pandemic record a song basically in my
living room and we had Kristen's sing
lead on it and what song was it by the
way for leaving you
know 2020 just as a like we're still a
band kind of little touch point we
released wind and myself which was
really you know always we were just in
Illinois I mean we're really always in
oh the band always but at that
particular time you know we were like
let's make a song like that like kind of
that right so that was a big change for
us because Kristin was singing lead and
it was the first song I had ever
produced for us and I was pretty nervous
about it because I was like what if we
put this on people like this sounds
terrible the production is terrible and
like you know coming off of the hills of
working with a famous producer and in a
big Studio or whatever like I just felt
really inadequate but I was like I just
got to put it out there and we'll see
what happens and you know as the
pandemic hit too just everything shut
down you know we had changed management
and agents and labels and so we were
fresh on the hills of like a new team
and and um I remember we put it out
didn't really hear anything so I was
like no bad news is good news and uh
then a few days later I was like mowing
my lawn and someone was like oh you guys
are your song is playing on like
SiriusXM on like all nation and I was
like oh what song and I looked and it
was the song that I had recorded like in
our living room and um and then it got
added a playlist on Spotify and all this
stuff and we uh that was a really
reaffirming moment and honestly that has
been kind of the overarching uh theme is
that it it never mattered like who we
worked with or what gear we used What
mattered was we just started really
riding from the heart and just we we got
to this point where we realized if we
don't feel something about the music
then then we can't expect other people
to so we only try to put out music that
made us feel something and you know you
kind of just answered what I was gonna
ask what have you learned I mean from
working with
but to have as few b-sides as humanly
possible because one thing we learned is
when you have a whole team and a label
like you don't always get to choose what
your singles are and so for previous
music
we didn't agree on those choices quite
often so we learned that
um
if that's the way that we have to do
professional music then we better just
not have any b-sides and be comfortable
with any any song
sort of being pushed up and so that is
one thing that we
you know we spent more time on these
songs than we had in the past we came
back to them sometimes and we didn't
used to do that you know I'm glazed we
did just on the spot you know right then
and there and it really made us Wonder
well what would we make if we didn't
have to do it in this 12-hour day
between 10 a.m and you know there's also
something powerful that I have learned
about like leaving stuff on The Chopping
you know on the shopping block or on The
Cutting Room floor or whatever because
there are a handful of songs that I can
think of off the top of my head where we
had recorded we had our drummer come out
from Nashville and we we recorded it
mixed it wrote the lyrics got all the
way to the finish line and then realized
like is this song doing anything for you
and Kristen be like not really and I'd
be like not really either and we would
just be like let's just put it in a
folder and let it sit and we'll come
back to it maybe later but there's
something powerful about that because I
think oftentimes you're trying to hit
some quota
well it's lovely to hear you describe it
that way considering
um what could have been left on The
Cutting Room floor is a little song
called Aquarius that
um I I gotta be honest with you I was
stunned stunned that that made it blown
me away the the the fact that you put in
horns just for me
uh yeah
of what this record was you know we
didn't take ourselves too seriously we
wanted to try things we wanted to like
you know we love Cage the Elephant let's
make a record like repeat repeat or
let's make a song that like repeat
repeat kind of Cage the Elephant style
or whatever you know we just got to try
things and not take ourselves
too seriously which is and we took
ourselves very seriously I think before
that before that yeah well we're
tremendously honest we're tremendously
honest we are Beyond I mean I think I'm
yeah speaking for taco and Brad I mean
that to for you guys to have done that
for us first of all was is amazing it's
such a great song and I love every time
I hear it and about every fourth or
fifth episode you know I'll be like
I can't believe that's our theme song
and then for it to be on this record is
that's actually the only part of the
podcast I ever listened back to yeah
and once Brad starts talking I don't
know anymore
that's fair trying to think on that side
the feeling you get you know we're
obviously huge Bonnaroo fans we attended
Bonnaroo many years before we got to
play Bonnaroo which will forever be and
hopefully it's not our last time to play
Bonnaroo but you know it will forever be
a huge beloved memory for us but um we
really when you guys gave us that
challenge we were
honored to accept it and felt like we
could really kind of dig deep and figure
out what the like real feel of Bonnaroo
and you guys and just hanging out there
in that Community was and not unlike our
other stuff it turned out very Lush and
I think kind of psychedelic 60s ish you
nailed it this is absolutely nailed it
yeah hasn't said nailed it um the other
song that I think gets a lot of
attention at least right now on the
album is Adult Friend Finder uh I I
don't think he probably anticipated that
part did you did you anticipate that
this would be the one that became like
the I don't know the standout track in
the early days of the album release no
absolutely not the story behind that was
um we were really into Peach pits song
shampoo bottles and we were like and
then we went to a wedding of a of a one
of my very close friends but you know I
feel like as you get older your friends
group as everyone moves away it's like
I'm remember we went to the wedding and
I was like half of my best friends
growing up in college like I don't even
know what they do for work anymore or
you know like one of them is expecting a
kid and I didn't really know that until
we went it's just like the fact that you
know these people so well over the
course of a handful of years and then as
you get older and life changes and
everything it's just how you grow kind
of grow apart but still you know I could
call any one of them at any moment and
they would be there for me
um just that weird kind of dynamic so I
wrote that song about that and
um our
one of our The Producers we worked with
is a guy named Gregory Latimer and he
worked on Albert Hammond Junior records
and Aaron Lee tashjin and a bunch of
other people and he did our first two
records bad latitude in Floral Canyon
and
um he had just done something with this
guy named John congleton who's this like
big producer worked with like always and
Angel Olsen St Vincent and so he had
also worked with Peach Pit so we were
like by way of John congleton like
Gregory probably would have some insight
on that like Peach Pit sound so it'd be
fun to work with Gregory again because
we hadn't worked with him in a few years
so I hit him up and I was like hey I've
got this song very Peach pity and I
thought maybe you'd have some good
Insight on it so we went to his studio
and recorded what was the last song so
it was like oh wow that was the last
song that we did and and we had already
had all the singles planned out so this
one was not tagged as a single it truly
was just the focus track for us to
release you know I mean you have to say
something is a focus track so that yeah
in the chance that you know something
gets playlisted they know what what song
to go for so it wasn't even really like
a single in our minds it was just sort
of like let's we're about to wrap up the
record let's do this fun thing with
Gregory and kind of throw it in there
and since it was one of the ones we
hadn't released as a single it just
became the natural Focus track but then
I don't think you know once we sort of
clicked that's the focus track I don't
think we thought anything else about
like anyone even picking up on the fact
that it was sort of isolated but then
what tends to happen or what has
happened a few times in the last year is
the ones that kind of
go on their own path often are because
they're um premiered by Regan yeah at um
All Nations yeah and every now and then
he'll just kind of go oh I love this
song and next thing we know it's it's
become a bigger song than we knew or I
had I I had dinner with him the other
night and uh you guys came up he's uh
he's a big fan he's a very big fan we
don't really know what we do to deserve
that but every time he sort of is
picking up what we're putting down we
feel just completely
full of gratitude so I feel like in this
industry I mean you just never know what
is gonna click with people and why so
you know it's like that song I like
Chris was saying a minute ago like we
just don't put out anything that we that
we wouldn't be that we would be bummed
if it didn't do well so when it started
picking up traction we were just like oh
what a pleasant surprise yeah it
certainly wasn't the one we would have
put our bets on but um well I mean
now with the album and
um you know the studio and and now post
quarantine are you guys trying to
get back on the road and do shows again
is that part of you know the plan for
next year or are you pretty content just
sort of hanging out the house no I'm
gonna let James I had a feeling I had a
feeling uh
someday there are some bands that that
really bring their audience uh through
playing shows and there are some bands
that really bring their audience through
releasing music and I think we're just
one of those that that uh I think we're
in our Brian Wilson phase where everyone
else is touring well you got a sandbox
[Laughter]
know gaining three fans at a time and we
have done that I mean for many years
like I I'm not one of those people that
that like
I feel like touring hard is a rite of
passage for a band I feel like when you
skip that stage or when you just get
like a radio hit and get to skip all of
the grueling touring years I mean not
for every genre of course like Pop's a
little different and stuff like that but
for rock and indie rock and stuff I feel
like you really have to kind of go
through that and we we toured hard I
mean in 2018 we spent more days gone
than we did here
um so I think you know then 2019 was a
busy year with the Black Keys Modest
Mouse tour and then well well not to
mention we have a lot of friends that
got back on the road pretty quickly
right and have canceled shows because
you know people can't afford to go out
to see them or have canceled shows
because of mental health because they
weren't prepared to go back out
um or because of the cost to keep a band
on the road
um not to mention I think I realized
over the last year that um touring is
pretty much the least
creative time you get to have as an
artist because you're just every day
you're just you're doing interviews and
then you're regurgitating the songs that
you you're promoting what you had
already put out but you're not getting
to be creative in the sense of like you
know you have a show that you've
practiced for months and it's just you
kind of like regurgitating that and I
think there's important moments for that
but uh I get to spend every single day
with a a new person sitting in the
studio getting to just make art and if
they're not in here I'm in here making
art for myself so I've never gotten to
be this creative in my life I love that
I mean [ __ ] even even if you're working
at a [ __ ] coffee shop while you're a
struggling artist you half the time
you're daydreaming about you know
whatever you're doing and writing lyrics
on napkins or whatever but
um tutoring is Denver to Kansas City
right when you're driving when you're
sitting in a van with a bunch of you
know guys and you're getting no sleep
and eating shitty food it's like you
really don't get to be your creative
self and I feel like I'm spoiled now I
get to just yeah but but also but
there's a time and place in somebody's
life for that kind of stuff and you guys
have just that you've done it and now
you just there's you want to be at home
I think it I have this I don't know just
this underlying fear that like you know
I
the band is gonna keep going we're gonna
it's not like we're gonna stop making
music and stop being repeat repeat or
whatever but I think we just have kind
of earned for ourselves the right to do
it a little bit differently for a second
yeah I mean you put out you put a in a
world of singles you put out an album
with 27 tracks you know yeah uh you're
doing it your way that's for sure yeah
like I think you know we used to tour
for different reasons like we should or
this is or like you know we were just
released an album and we should
immediately be touring but should we
like how do we know that how do we know
how can we really quantify that like
there's gonna be people there so we've
kind of what's my return on investment
yeah exactly so
our return is like blaring us and you
know like knocking on the door then
it'll be easy for us to see and we'll
get back out there but I think well and
the studio spooked until the spring
anyway so if we go unless we get unless
we get some amazing show or gig
um I would have to cancel making records
I mean I'm booked solid until April so
uh you know I just we couldn't even our
booking agent doesn't love that but but
uh you know it's like if I get I get
paid for people to come here to my
property and make music all day so I'm
like why would I want to and guess and
guess how and guess how many uh
percentages other people take from that
yeah right
on the road
one of my favorite uh interview answers
and I don't remember who it was but we
were talking about they had had a hit
record and we're getting ready to do
their second album and you know there's
the sophomore Jinx where and we were
talking about that whole creative thing
you know you just now spent 14 months on
the road and and how do you write a song
and he said yeah nobody cares that your
bus driver's having a bad day that
that's not a giveaway but when you are
the bus but that's all you're the bus
driver
so I might be okay
right yeah uh well you know one the
other thing that I was going to ask you
guys because you're such a major part of
the National Music Scene what were your
thoughts on the exit in uh closing and
and subsequent destruction yeah and now
going going away forever
I mean
Exodus a huge deal it's a legendary
venue we've played we we oh we played a
sold out show opening for glass animals
there
um many years ago we played
several shows there so did they not
announce a new owner they did announce a
new did they I think they did the other
day you would know better than I I'm not
plugged into it but if uh it was like 48
hours ago they did announce a new oh
really
very interesting okay
um wait I thought that would do am I
wrong about this wasn't your your how
your Halloween show at exited every year
didn't you do it there or was it
somewhere else The Crying Wolf and he's
now oh that's right that's right that's
right so that sort of two
years um so crying wolf is the place
that we used to do our Halloween show
for seven years straight and they closed
last year so not that accident was just
another one on the chopping block at all
but I will say as far as like
how we sort of take the news these days
as I think we can expect it to be honest
so much has changed Nashville it feels
like sad to hear yeah I mean it's just
like it's all
but but that's but that's the story of
every city in the country though yeah
you know we're from Austin so I feel
like I'm just watching the same thing
happened and
I know you were from Austin why did I
not know that yeah I'm from like Katie
and then my house to Austin so I spent
most of my like college Years coming
back to Austin and
well I will say that that is the one the
two things about this well that's two
things those two cities are so
incredibly alike because they've become
just a big J crew
everybody looks the same wearing the
same dumb hat uh they're all just living
the same sort of existence and it feels
odd to be in last time I like I used to
love Austin and I love ACL Fest and that
city was so fantastic especially being
so close to New Orleans there for a
while but last time I went first off the
homelessness is completely out of
control and that's coming from a guy who
lived in New Orleans the homelessness is
out of control but secondly it just
feels paralyzing and suffocating the
fact that everyone looks exactly the
same and they're all just sort of doing
the same thing and National sort of
getting there when you're in it city
right the thing that everybody loves
about it then they sort of embrace and
become and then it just becomes this
giant mass of sameness I mean there was
a scene I mean it's funny you said the
Nashville music scene and there was part
of me that thought like is there even
really like much of a scene anymore and
I know that sounds so like old well you
would be the one to ask is me but it's
it's just you know uh
uh no I don't really think that there is
much of one I think that there's just so
much newness and so many
people coming from different places
trying to figure out what to do that
it's just it's created a lot of
Disconnect and then of course the um the
increase in housing costs you know the
like East Nashville used to be all
artists and musicians and you know we we
moved an hour away so what does that
tell you you know we were right in the
thick of it for many years and and
had to move an hour away to like create
the life that we wanted you know
man uh Barry what did you learn about
did you look up the exit in thing
yeah in November they said a new group
looked like would be man I missed all of
that see there's this thing like um I
have become I don't know what happened
but since moving here I have never been
more disconnected from literally
everything
I moved to this I moved to the center of
the world and now I'm disconnected from
everything I have no earthly idea what's
going on on the flip end move to the
middle of nowhere and the same thing
happened because that I mean I don't I
work here and I live here and so I don't
ever I mean I mean I felt legitimately
like upset with myself last night's uh a
friend of ours said man I cannot believe
this Idaho murder thing and I'm like I
have no idea what you're talking about
and I look up this morning and I'm like
oh my god what have I been doing uh you
know if it doesn't like come across the
for the five seconds that I'm on
Instagram or the five seconds I'm on
Twitter I just don't know what happens
or like the Andrew Tate thing or
whatever is I think that's his name and
there was some meme that was like I have
no idea who this guy is but let's get
him
you know what I mean that was fixing me
I was like yeah that dude sucks but I
don't I don't know you couldn't I don't
know if he's an auto mechanic or a
podcaster or an influencer I don't know
what he does I don't know who he is but
I'm like cool man get him I don't know
whatever I I swear to God Hand to God I
have no idea what you're talking about I
have no idea what you're talking about I
know what I mentioned let's get him yeah
yeah cancel yeah cancel I don't know I
want him I want him gone
we deleted our Twitter because it just
it was uh partially just when Twitter
got crazy but partially because we were
on there for seven years and couldn't
get more Twitter was not good to us yeah
yeah the day it got like really weird
the first day it got weird Jared was
like let's just get rid of it and I was
like I mean it hasn't done us any favors
and we just still see and honestly
getting rid of one of the well between
that and what is it Instagram and Tick
Tock and Facebook but getting rid of one
of them was like so free not having that
one less thing to check but Twitter was
my news source which is sort of it is
yeah to Brad is like I now feel like I
have no idea what's going on because we
took that one immediately that was my
one new song which I don't know what
that says about me but I'm having to
find news elsewhere I tell you I tell
you the the um once like the daily freak
out of trump left our lives I I don't
really engage in this anymore and the
other thing too is about Twitter is the
only reason I'm on it I I love Twitter
to be totally Frank but I like it mostly
because I am streaming sports like I'm a
Washington then Redskins now commanders
fan so I have to watch the stream
backward like I'm I'm behind 10 15 20
seconds I use Twitter mostly just on on
Sundays to get the play that happened so
I don't like that's about to be shown to
me that's really the only reason I'm on
this this social media app and I say
this to everybody and taco knows this
better than anyone I love Snapchat
Snapchat's the best social media on the
planet it's the best app that you can
have because it's completely
controllable by you you control all of
your intake and all of what you put out
and what you put out is only to the
people that you want it it's fantastic
um yeah 175 is our snap streak right now
Brad my man 175.
Tick Tock and in the beginning he was
like I'm gonna just make an 88 out of
myself on Tick Tock like everybody else
because why not but then you swung card
the other day well because what happened
was I feel like any of these any of the
social medias are like you set your mind
out to do one thing and then it like
sucks you in a whole nother world so
it's like I I learned a lot about
production on Tick Tock like really yeah
I learned so many I mean that's one
thing I really miss about it frankly is
like I would learn so much about like
you know monitors and miking and
techniques and stuff like that it was
really fascinating
um but then you just you do this in the
scroll and then soon enough you're like
you're like oh my gosh so and so did The
Tick Tock dance and I'm just like why do
I care about this [ __ ] like I don't and
you just find yourself like sitting on
the edge of the bed like at two in the
morning you're just like
I I just was like I only had one
sleeting moment with Tick Tock and that
was when everything was a cake oh yeah I
uh loved when everything was a cake is
this live baby a cake I don't know let's
cut it yeah yeah well it's it's honestly
I think it's really nice now to just
like because I just I'm on Instagram for
the studio and the band and then um it
links to our Facebook which I don't even
check Facebook anymore never never ever
ever yeah yeah Facebook is having our
mother-in-law visiting we realize
Facebook is for like your parents to
check in on your friends from high
school right you know what I mean it'll
be like yeah yeah so I see my my social
thing and I don't know why I do this I
talk about it all the time I can't stop
watching like how to camp in Sub-Zero
weather
on YouTube I will I will never in my
life do that but I know how to camp in a
tent you know in 30 below zero I'm like
why am I walking because you know again
so we might be watching yeah but even
that stuff you find yourself like all of
a sudden in this brain fog because I had
YouTube on for the our dogs were
watching YouTube in their in their dog
room and
and all of a sudden I found myself like
it was it was on and I walked in and it
was like it was like rural cities in
Missouri oh right and I sat there and I
watched for like 25 minutes and I was
like why do I give a [ __ ] about real
cities in Missouri exactly why am I
watching this I think I think you should
ask your dogs the same question I mean
they're the ones watching it yeah I'm
watching a guy cut vegetables in the
back of his truck and it's 20 below zero
and I'm like why am I watching this so
you know it's kind of green to like you
know I I'll get like some pop singer
here and they'll be like did you hear
about so and so they said this and they
got they her and blah blah got split up
and it's really nice to just be like I
have no clue yeah no and you know I was
talking to a fellow bonnaroovian uh
friend the other day we get beers on
occasion and he's like are you lit or do
you what do you think about the latest
rumor like I have no idea uh I have no I
honestly don't even know what day it is
I I don't know what day the I don't even
know when the festival is I uh I am so
disconnected from the world and I don't
uh I know why you would do it in the
middle of nowhere but it's it just feels
weird in the biggest city in the world
to be so disconnected and I realize
because it's it's it's a very isolating
existence you know we didn't buy one
Christmas present for anyone this year
not one not even for each other because
why sure in a minute
what about all the money we raised well
I'm still working on yours I'm still
working on yours yeah you made some
promises yeah
I'm working on it
um but we didn't do it
like essentially you can order things
online but if I don't walk directly past
a store that's is something I'm gonna
walk into and shop and I'm not going
it's too far it's too too hard
I feel like people in New York never
like leave their block they got
everything uh oh yeah we go we go we
look I just I just put out this morning
this is the list of shows since being in
New York this is the list of shows I've
gone to since being here I mean I'm in
like the 50s at this point we go
somewhere every day we're doing
something every day but
um it's such like a point A to point B
like I'm not I'm not like stopping my
train so I can get out and you know go
shopping for anybody it just feels like
a weird existence
um and not exactly what I was
anticipating being so disconnected from
everything interesting and makes sense
and it's not something that that would
probably occur to most people but
that makes sense yeah yeah also we don't
you know I operate TV a lot like your
dogs do you know I'll turn on something
that makes no sense and watch it for
four hours and you know it's gotten me
nowhere in life yeah um they've watched
The Weird Al movie twice they love it oh
wow I haven't even got into the Weird Al
movie well there was there was a moment
during the pandemic like I would put on
like I would they were watching
Kristen I'm
more scump on for the dogs you know
we put a movie
movie
this is absurd guys guys the dogs don't
know this it's funny um one thing bad
you don't know
what movies are they watching oh I
forgot about that one is it just like a
random like wheel that you could spend
like if you walked in another movie has
started on a on a whim that they you
didn't set up for the sleep timer so oh
okay okay
that's right
did they get iPad time as well or is it
just yeah
on a tight ship I will say I will say
there there is a market for a live
stream of dogs just watching TV you
could you could start and then other
dogs could watch that yeah
see that's why he's who he is into this
show for the longest time called The
People's Couch and it's just a show
where they have different families and
like roommates and you watch them
watching like the latest episodes of
reality TV but their reactions are so
funny it was very Black Mirror it's
great very very good this is very weird
this is very weird I I did actually have
one question back to the album real
quick I hate that we just jumped around
everywhere but
um if you put out something like 27
songs and you've done this over the
course of you know two years is there
one song in particular that you're like
I really really want people to like this
one yes which one
I there's so many songs I have to
remember okay okay anytime somebody asks
what's our favorite song
all of a sudden not no but was it
already a single was it a single oh okay
uh what's the dog's favorite yeah
guys I've been married to this person
for 11 years
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I know which one
is yeah it's tripping yeah sorry I can't
remember all the titles there's so many
there's a lot of songs man I mean just
be honest this is a lot I wrote that
song like three years
the guy who wrote and produced the album
I can't remember the title
I mean the album that we sort of said
from the get-go that we wanted to make
regardless of you know whether or not it
was like the right song for us to make
stylistically or but just this was a
type of song that we wanted to have in
our repertoire and it's a type of song
similar to songs that we would listen to
and gravitate toward so that song is
tripping and what we love about that
song is I feel like it is like a roller
skating song and I learned through
making that song that I like songs that
have kind of this like you can roller
skate too but there's something about
that song that kind of hit a lot of
marks for us
um in terms of what we like but isn't
necessarily what's commercially viable
so we sort of knew that it was probably
only going to be our favorite song but
anytime someone else goes I really love
tripping
I I think that's the song that we really
feel like
well if you get the right if you get the
right influence or roller skating and
put that song on Tick Tock at the same
time the sink is happening the sink is
happening uh guys I love I love I love
you guys so much I'm so happy to see
your faces I'm so excited to see the the
the the space for the first time uh I
feel like in for the first I mean as
close to real life as it's gonna get and
um are you guys there
see there's the French doors with the
view oh God and the couches and behind
behind the thing is the kitchen but I
can't flip the and it's and it sounds
pretty good huh I see the soundproofing
on the walls it sounds pretty good we
had it built custom so it's uh fully
like we paid for this fancy insulation
and it's insulated from the roof all the
way to the floor and uh we've got all
the sound from the windows to the walls
right exactly
enough electricity City in these 600
square feet for like a five bedroom five
bedroom house so there's a lot of
information and a lot of power
and well the biggest the biggest
question of course are we going to see
you in June
are you guys going to come down
here
yeah we we may this would be kind of the
first year that we actually would be
able to because every other year we've
been you know the one year we played it
in pretty much every other year since
we've been on the road during that time
well will you will you guys want to be a
part of Camp nut butter do you want to
come camp with us during the camper come
join the campers into that area I'll
make it happen we'll make it happen
yeah yeah yeah I mean that I mean Taco
brings a bus
it's the same it's the same thing
exactly yeah I think we can do it okay
let's do it all right are you are you
we'll save you a spot are you gonna even
know when it is yes yes
we'll see
um I actually did talk to Evan Bonnaroo
about this the other night I because he
drives down from from New York I'm not
doing that I just can't but I will fly
maybe into like Chattanooga and then
rent a car I guess or get somebody to
let me borrow a car I don't really know
I haven't really worked it out but yes
we are absolutely planning on being
there this year I got extra cars yeah
you got a lot of cars wait what is our
wait what is our tour manager always put
on our guest list what's the name
spaghetti Joe spaghetti dance spaghetti
dance so if we end up playing it we
always every show we always put one
person on the guest that's named
spaghetti Dan so that's it in if
somebody knows that they can get into
our show for free so if we end up
playing Bonnaroo you could get a free
pass in and just say you're gonna be Dan
are you guys actively talking about it
uh between the two of us maybe but
that's about it okay all right has Joe
not made that call have we not made the
call yet I don't know that this is our
year for for okay for our next comeback
to it okay all right well either way I
want you guys please come down and uh I
mean you know you have tickets so so
come down and camp at least a day come
down for at least a night you're too
close you're too close not to let's do
it we'll do it we'll come see you guys
if that's the only way we get to see you
in person Brad yeah
you're starting to sound like hurricane
Linda
yeah
I could be like I'll be like are you
coming to visit and he's like no no no
no I'm just letting you know I'm in the
same area code or the same zip code I'm
like cool great thanks
at least at least you get those taco and
I get hey my tire's flat yeah you can
come fix it jump my car come jump my car
yeah there you go I've got a good family
guys I love you so much thank you for
this and and thanks for the uh and
really thanks for the album and for
anybody that's listening or watching if
you haven't spent some time with us
listen to about for six seven hours uh
and then you'll love it yes yeah it only
takes six or seven hours
in yeah yeah I really know I couldn't
say better things about this album it is
so so so good and you know yeah there's
27 songs on it but I really legit think
there are five six seven incredible
maybe the best stuff you guys have ever
put out on this record so
um I mean Arrangements in and of itself
is so so good yeah it's a great album
it's a really really well done album and
in the art yeah it works with YouTube
always sort of understanding what we're
trying to do and put out into the world
and they'll be there'll be more we're
already working on new stuff so yeah oh
my gosh
oh really person's learning Bass
wow that's very wet leg of you all right
yeah I uh it was very dead of me I'm
wearing a dead shirt right now oh I love
the dead yeah yeah I picked up base over
I guess it was like a couple months ago
but
I don't know I went I got really into it
and then I'm married to a music teacher
basically so he uh he has fostered that
quite a bit and then I got some
Christmas presents to go along with it
so
the next time you see us play Live you
might see Kristen
you're you're really close he's gonna do
it Taco's gonna do the joke he's gonna
do this lavender oh God I can't
stop the face do it okay slap at the
base thank you I know you're just going
to all right guys thanks so much we'll
talk to you soon thank you
tell Mom I said hi love you guys
hurricane Linda bye bye
[Music]
oh
consequence podcast Network